uh we're gonna kick you in the teeth all
right and when you punch his back we're
gonna smile at you and when you knock us
down
we're gonna get up and on the way up
we're gonna bite a kneecap off
all right and we're gonna stand up and
then it's gonna take two more shots to
knock us down
all right and on the way up we're going
to take your other kneecap and we're
going to get up and then it's going to
take three shots to get us down and when
we do we're going to take another hunk
out of you before
before long where they're going to be
the last one standing all right that's
going to be the mentality
a lot of penalty flags a lot of fines
imposed and eventually suspensions for
physically removing kneecaps without
anesthesia
from opponents but that was dan campbell
with his snl level introductory press
conference shireen
what do you think his impact is really
going to be once things settle down and
presumably he's not
coaching up players on how to remove
kneecaps with their teeth
i think the players are going to love
him mike but it's going to take a while
there this is just
not a very good roster right now which
is why he got the long-term deal he has
time to build the program that he wants
to build
they think they have the quarterback i
know brad holmes really believes in
jerry goff if that's the case they have
a good starting block right to try to
rebuild this thing
but they have a lot of problems
offensively defensively where you want
to start i think you pick the best
players at this point to come in and
help you
and i think the fact that that they gave
up matthew stafford they brought in a
jared goff who is clearly at an early
career
crossroads and you didn't get
significant compensation for stafford
this year they are rebuilding
they have convinced the powers that be
that this is going to take some time and
campbell has a six-year contract a
that's more like an anti-dysfunction
contract to show that
you know they're not going to keep
spinning the revolving door on coach
with another and another and another but
if it's a disaster they will it's a cost
of doing business you pay
the balance of the contract and you move
on if it comes down to it
um between dan campbell and chris beam
and a couple of former players
it's an interesting way to approach the
game
it will be old school it will be
hard-nosed they will be
preaching rough and tough and gritty and
we'll see how it goes i you know i'm not
going to rule out anything because
sometimes the one thing that is so
different from everything else
works just because no one else is used
to it everybody else has gone
in a different direction maybe maybe a
throwback
to the days where it was a lot more
physical and a lot more
violent and a lot more rough and tumble
maybe that'll be disarming in a positive
way for the lions even though guys will
be
fine and guys will be suspended if they
play that way shireen
and i think they're going to play hard
for dane campbell i do think they'll
play that way i think they're going to
be hard-hitting and
we'll probably see some flags for for
the hard hits that they deliver but this
is going to
be a team that you're going to you know
look be looking over your shoulder when
you play them for sure because i do
think they're going to play hard and
they're going to play rough and they're
going to be tough
uh and they're going to play to the end
and they're going to play to the whistle
and maybe sometimes beyond the whistle
but
i i do think they will play hard mike
and i just don't know how that
converts to wins because i don't think
there are many of them there
but i don't think they'll go oh and 16
either i think that
toughness and that mentality and and all
of that playing hard i think it does to
convert to some wins they're not going
to have another one 16 season
they definitely won't go in 16 there is
a chance they'll be on 17 though
so there's a new barrier that's true the
lions cross if they choose to do it
uh jared goff the new quarterback
on the surface i i don't see an instant
personality blend
between goff and dan campbell do you
think goff is the long-term answer
or is this just a we need a quarterback
we were willing to spend the money and
burn up the cap space to get two
first-round picks and a third-round pick
in the matthew stafford trade i mean do
they really think this is a guy they're
gonna build around
i think they find that out this year
mike they they
it's kind of a let's get to know you
type year they don't expect a whole lot
i mean what if they go out and win
six games seven games and or right
around the 500
mark which they didn't expect to be i
mean i would expect this team to win
four or five games
if they win way more than that maybe he
is your quarterback of the future i mean
he does have a winning record in
in the league that's hard to do i don't
care what team you're on it's still hard
to do
over the course of the career to be 42
and 27 and this guy has
started in his super bowl so he's got
some things that you like so i think
this is kind of a
feel me out year to see if it if it
works
but i also don't rule out that they're
going to draft a quarterback mike that
maybe that's their guy of the future
and keep this in mind when the schedule
comes out in april as it usually does
four road games for the lions this year
cleveland pittsburgh
chicago and green bay the potential to
be cold weather and we've seen in the
past
that jared goff isn't a big fan of
although he quitted himself well in his
last game with the rams it was out in
the elements in green bay and
and it didn't seem to have the kind of
impact that the game in chicago did a
couple of years ago all right let's go
through the
who's in who's out shereen give me one
name of a guy that you think the lions
will target
a guy that the glides will turn i'm
gonna go all williams since my last name
is williams i i had marcus williams and
jamal williams on my list but i'm going
to go with marcus williams
you know they don't have a ton of money
to spend they're not going to spend a
ton on free agents but
i think he would be a guy maybe that you
spend a little bit more on
and he will help fix some things that
you didn't have in your secondary
uh since you traded all your good
players out of the secondary but he'd be
great for jeff okuda who they used the
third overall pick on last year i just
think he would he would
fit what they want to do in detroit
and i had jamal williams too because i
think he would pair
well with swift which i know they're
they're looking to do and he would pair
better with swift
uh than say adrian peterson did
for me i engaged in some high level film
study and analysis
from mine matt milano a bill's
linebacker hey chris spielman was once a
bill's
once a bill's linebacker and if anybody
on the field is going to be biting off
kneecaps it's going to be a linebacker
so i i could see the bills or the lines
with spielman having an all linebacker
defense a bunch of hard-nosed tough guys
who will bite off your kneecap and if
they are successful it will make it
easier to
to defeat the opponent all right who's
out
sticking with williams theme here nick
williams is going to be out
uh 21 2021 cap of 5.7 million they can
save
4.7 million against the cap he
had 13 starts this year played in 14
games 23 tackles and a sack mike
that's not enough for the salary he's
supposed to make you say bye to nick
williams for this year
yeah and with tj hawkinson being such a
good tight end i think the jesse james
era in detroit will be over also they
gotta do something about running back
because deandre swift has worked out so
it's either going to be carry on johnson
or adrian peterson see you later and i
could see
the lions being attracted to the concept
of keeping a guy like peterson around
because of the leadership he brings to
the table
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports